well this March is now breaking up and
it comes after more than a week have
relative calm here in Hong Kong relative
calm now many of the protesters are
wearing face masks in defiance of course
of that ban imposed by Hong Kong police
more than a week ago warning that if
people did wear face masks they risked
arrest and also being heavily fined well
that hasn't deterred some of these
protesters now this March didn't pass
without incident to MTR train stations
were attacked one of them had a petrol
bomb thrown into it there were no
injuries also an outlet of Starbucks was
once more attacked
it had its window shattered Starbucks of
course has become a popular target for
these protesters a lot of the protesters
here have also been talking about the
comments that have come from President
Donald Trump who says that he thinks
that the protests are now in his words
de-escalating well a lot of the
protesters don't know whether that means
that the United States is now showing
the same sort of support that it did for
the protest movement that's to say
support from US politicians as they had
say several months ago now the
protesters say they are going to gather
again on Sunday for unspecified action
certainly the protests are not on a
scale that we were seeing several weeks
or even several months ago there is
still violence but it's not as intense
as it has been in recent weeks